foreign
by the rise of literacy a few hundred
years ago many people in society thought
that maybe not everyone needed to be
able to read and write back then many
people were attending feuds or hurting
sheep so maybe there was less need for
written communication and all that was
needed was for the high priests and
priestesses and monks to be able to read
the holy book and the rest of us could
just go to the temple or church or the
holy building and sit and listen to the
high priests and priestesses read to us
fortunately it was since figured out
that we can build a much richer Society
if lots of people could read and write
today AI is in the hands of the high
priests and priestesses these are the
highly skilled AI Engineers many of whom
work in the big tech companies
and most people have access only to the
AI that they built for them
I think that we can build a much richer
Society if we can enable everyone to
help to write the future
but why is AI largely concentrated in
the big tech companies because many of
these AI projects have been expensive to
build they may require dozens of Highly
skill engineers and it may cause
millions or tens of millions of dollars
to build an AI system
and the large tech companies
particularly the ones with hundreds of
millions or even billions of users have
been better than anyone else at making
these Investments pay off because for
them a one-size-fits-all AI system such
as one that improves web search or that
recommends better products for online
shopping can be applied to this very
large number of users to generate a
massive amount of Revenue
but this recipe for AI does not work
once you go outside to Tech and internet
sectors to other places where for the
most part there are hardly any projects
that apply to 100 million people or that
generates comparable economics
let me illustrate an example
many weekends I drive a few minutes from
my house to a local pizza store to buy a
slice of Hawaiian pizza from the
gentleman that owns this pizza store and
his pizza is great but he always has a
lot of cold pizzas sitting around and
every weekend some different flavor of
pizza is all the stuff
but when I watch him operate his store I
get excited because by selling pizza he
is generating data and this is data that
you can take advantage of if he had
access to AI
AI systems are good at spotting patterns
when given access to the right data and
perhaps an AI system could spot if
Mediterranean pizzas sell really well on
a Friday night maybe because suggest to
him to make more of it on a Friday
afternoon
now you might say to me hey Andrew this
is a small pizza store what's the big
deal
and I say to the gentleman that owns
this pizza store something that could
help him improve his revenues by a few
thousand dollars a year that will be a
huge deal to him
I know that there is a lot of hype about
ai's need for massive data sets and
having more data does help
but contrary to the hype AI can often
work just fine even on Modest amounts of
data such as the data generated by a
single piece of store
so the real problem is not that there
isn't enough data from the pieces law
the real problem is that this small
pizza store could never serve enough
customers to justify the cost of hiring
an AI team
I know that in the United States they're
about half a million independent
restaurants and collectively these
restaurants do serve tens of millions of
customers but every restaurant is
different with a different menu
different customers different ways of
recording sales that no
one-size-fits-all AI will work for all
of them
what would it be like if we could enable
small businesses and especially local
businesses to use AI let's take a look
at what it might look like at a company
that makes and sells t-shirts I would
love if an accountants working for the
t-shirt company can use AI for demand
forecasting say figure out what funny
memes to print on T-shirts that would
drive sales by looking at what's
trending on social media
or for product placements why can't a
frontal store manager take pictures of
what the store looks like and show it to
an AI and have an AI recommend where to
place products to improve sales supply
chain can any I recommend to a buyer
whether or not they should pay twenty
dollars per yard for a piece of fabric
now or if they should keep looking
because they might be able to find the
cheaper elsewhere
or quality control a Quality Inspector
should be able to use AI to
automatically scan pictures of the
fabric being used to make t-shirts to
check if there are any tears or
discolorations in the cloth
today large tech companies routinely use
AI to solve problems like these and to
create effects
but a typical t-shirt company or a
typical auto mechanic or retailer or
school or local Farm we'll be using AI
for exactly zero of these applications
today
every T-shirt maker is sufficiently
different from every other T-shirt maker
that there is no one size bizal AI that
will work for all of them
and in fact once you go outside the
internet and Tech sectors
in other Industries even large companies
such as the pharmaceutical companies the
car makers the hospitals also struggle
with this
this is the long tail problem of AI
if you were to take all current and
potential AI projects and sort them in
decreasing order of value and plot them
you get drafted looks like this maybe
the single most valuable AI system is
something that decides what ads to show
people on the internet maybe the second
most valuable is a web search engine
maybe the third most valuable is a
online shopping product recommendation
system
but when you go to the right of this
curve you then get projects like t-shirt
product placements or t-shirt demand
forecasting or Pizzeria demand
forecasting and each of these is a
unique project that needs to be custom
built even t-shirt demand forecasting if
it depends on trending memes on the on
social media is a very different project
than Pizzeria demand forecasting if that
depends on the pizzeria sales data
so today there are millions of projects
sitting on the tail of this distribution
that no one is working on but whose
aggregate value is massive
so how can we enable small businesses
and individuals to build AI systems that
matter to them
for most of the last few decades if you
want to build an AI system this is what
you have to do you have to write pages
and pages of code
and while I would love for everyone to
learn to code and in fact online
education and also offline education are
helping more people than ever learn to
go unfortunately not everyone has the
time to do this
but there is an emerging new way to
build AI systems that will let more
people participate just as pen and paper
which are a vastly superior technology
to Stone tablet and chisel were
instrumental to widespread literacy
there are emerging new AI development
platforms that shift the focus from
asking you to write lots of code to
asking you to focus on providing data
and this turns out to be much easier for
a lot of people to do
today there there are multiple companies
working on platforms like these let me
illustrate a few of the concepts using
one that my team has been building
take the example of an inspector wanting
AI to help detect defects in fabric an
inspector can take pictures of the
fabric and upload it to a platform like
this and they can go in to show the AI
what tears in the fabric looks like by
drawing rectangles and they can also go
in to show the AI what discolorations
and the fabric looks like by drawing
rectangles
so these pictures together with the
green and pink rectangles that the
inspectors drawn are data created by the
inspector to explain to AI how to find
tears and discolorations
after the AI examines this data we may
find that it has seen enough pictures of
tears but not yet enough pictures of
discolorations this is akin to a junior
inspector had learned to rely terrorists
but still needs to further hone their
judgment about discolorations so the
inspector can go back and take more
pictures of discolorations to show to
the AI to help it deepen its
understanding by adjusting the data you
give to the AI you can help the AI get
smarter
so an inspector using an accessible
platform like this can in a few hours to
a few days and with a up with purchasing
a suitable camera setup be able to build
a custom AI system to detect defects
tears and discussions in all the fabric
being used to make t-shirts throughout
the factory
and once again you may ask you may say
hey Andrew
this is one Factory like why is this a
big deal
and I say to you this is a big deal to
that inspector whose life just makes
easier and equally this type of
Technology can Empower a baker to use AI
to check for the quality of the kicks
they're making or a organic farmer to
check the quality of the vegetables or a
Furniture maker to check the quality of
the wood they're using
platforms like these will probably still
need a few more years before they're
easy enough to use for every pizzeria
owner but many of these platforms are
coming along and some of them are
getting to be quite useful to someone
that is tech savvy today with just a bit
of training but what this means is that
rather than relying on the high priests
and priestesses the right AI systems for
everyone else we can start to empower
every accountant every store manager
every buyer and every Quality Inspector
to build their own AI systems
I hope that's the pizzeria owner and
many other small business owners like
him will also take advantage of this
technology because AI is creating
tremendous wealth and will continue to
create tremendous world and it's only by
democratizing access to AI that can
ensure that this wealth is spread far
and wide across Society
hundreds of years ago I think hardly
anyone
understood the impact that widespread
literacy will have today I think hardly
anyone understands the impact that
democratizing access to AI will have
building AI systems has been Out Of
Reach for most people but that does not
have to be the case in the coming era of
AI will Empower everyone to build AI
systems for themselves and I think that
will be incredibly exciting future thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]